c'est claude santelli qu'a eu ce
privilège de recueillir la dernière
interview télévisée de jean louis
barrault c'était en novembre 90 le
comédien évoque son premier rôle dans
une pièce de cervantès
à
33,37 et
dimanche d'après cervantès ou mais c'est
ça tu as beau
c'est le premier grand risque de votre
mix prix d'autres prévues toujours pris
des risques mais
c'est pour les riches à cet été
à désir de le faire
claudel est venu me voir pour galvauder
tout le temps on était très amis
avec l'hôtel on avait un magnifique mâle
mais vite
pour le travail
pvt
composé charles
grande fête et
vous avez conservé comme comme enseigne
comme saint seulement comme symbole de
notre
activité théâtrale
au
cab la wii
et
mm en cochon c'est bien l'achat
en bas à droite roger blin
tout ça ce sont des très bons souvenirs
vont mener chalker